hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Anna all right I got this
funny feeling just a strange feeling
that I'm supposed to put the seeds in
the water I don't know it's just like a
thumb that came over me
I think I'm supposed to do this pretty
sure and I came up with this idea all by
myself all by myself okay so see you
back Wow whoa holy hell
weird light floating around now these
seeds grow quickly very quickly
no kidding okay and then what up what up
what up okay okay
and so I'm supposed to go I uh wait I've
got another feeling coming in oh oh oh
upstairs I go upstairs and then I oh I
find the top of the tree okay yeah yeah
it's all coming back to me now it's all
coming to me my super gaming ability
it's just reaching a peak oh ah so ah
okay so anyway I gotta find where it
popped up
[Music]
I need for it to begin weeping do I stab
it
I bet I stab it Oh new new wave legs I
pick it up with the mole I have
collected some blood and now hello blast
blood on wall hey but ok music just
picked up like seriously
all right don't know why there was blood
in the tree but I guess I won't ask
questions by now
sploosh my sweetest mother once once
upon a time I quenched my thirst from
thy breast today I shall pay the price
of that forgotten memory I've got my eye
on you buddy Oh
[Music]
she is speaking to me I can feel her
presence deep within my corporeal form
and I just given me her key and has just
given me your key it's up to me whether
to go and meet her or to flee stop
bother okay so what do I do now and let
me say that I feel like a important
decision might be coming up so let me
just save real quick I might be getting
close to the end of the game who knows
okay so the facer or to flee
can use that baby still there it's badly
wounding maybe because how stabbed it I
stabbed it in his eyeballs hey babbit
okay so slash blood on that okay so I
don't see anything else up here oh there
it is the key ah
Anna's key god I didn't even know I
thought it was like a metaphor cooky
that I made in house phrase did the
force that is trailing me maybe I feel
so bad because of what I've just
discovered in there such a gorgeous girl
cutie that way I didn't maybe she was
the same girl I'm in the wood today I
injured myself she was so full of grace
and gentleness back then I think I was
engaged already I can't even remember -
it's hard not to think about you even
now
I see red flames and the wind whispering
in creepy verses something fierce and is
lurking in the woods I wasn't able to
flee I'm hers corrupted in body and mind
that was it that was it
Oh aah hang on I gotta go back cuz there
must be something else there's got to be
something else to this right shut up
okay there's got to be something else
right right right right right
okay it's still playing time on so I can
explore a bit more can those boards are
just like floating that's weird okay
anyway maybe I could try to use the key
on this door to try to run away instead
of going to where I think I think that
was like to go to her ending that's not
going to work it won't open the lock is
jammed okay maybe there isn't another
way out that might be the only exit I
don't know if that's the only ending but
I kind of want to figure out if there's
another one
this what was the point of this ah a lot
of these things I just don't know what
the point is Wow yeah I just what the
point is all right something else before
I give up on this
it isn't scary okay there's gotta be
something with this door on the path oh
oh the key on this door
perfect yes I knew there was something
else I knew there was something else I
knew it I knew it I knew it I knew it
your devoted servant has gained access
to thy womb again my beloved I can no
longer hide myself that's weird that's
weird
okay central mirror
whosoever covets light baguettes shade
can't use it can't get it gap here where
I'd I expect nothing but imminent death
were I to leap into the darkness yeah
that makes sense okay I just got to move
these mirrors the vanity of light
reflects itself in this place yet out of
time Mirror Mirror
you're its admirer I just got to rotate
these nope almost got it
I just went yeah I can't move it anymore
really that's it that's all I got okay I
just got to get through all of these
beams pointing to the middle okay there
what come on
that was it right must be something else
that I need to do where did I get that
where did I get that not yet the light
beams are still wrongly set I can't move
them anymore
all of them are our maximum we moved the
mirror rejects it weird the mirror
rejects it ah ah huh whoa ah come on
really why the freaky practice that
happen and it's it's totally effed up
it's oh you gotta became a gotta be good
okay I'll be back in a bit
god damnit and we're back okay sorry
about that guys I don't know why that
keeps happening probably just cuz it's
an indie game it's a little unstable it
just keeps either crashing or all timing
are all padding and crashing I don't
know but I'm getting back at least I'm
not very far from where we were the [ __ ]
I get in there and then I use the weird
masks Oh truth lalalala and access to
your wound rotate these
get these in posies shown come on now do
you think I could just wrote it in the
correct rotated into the correct
position one but no it's got beat doosh
take them up
all right so let me try the face of the
mirror reject okay this is the face of
truth mirror uh-huh and this is the face
of the whatchamacallit vascular divine
mirror rejects it mirror accept it it
generates a strange entity when touched
okay can't use it but I can't oh I get
it
okay so I just need to pick him back up
again ah
that means this bunk just like that
pick it up and then put this here face
of truth right there perfect pick it up
and we're good now I can put the face of
truth truth on there I need to be strong
Lisette oh come on
really needs to be done okay all right
Oh Hot Diggity maybe I got to get all
the beams read can a mirror check
something
did that mirror mirror rejects both of
them can that add the face of truth in
the beginning he rejects it here rejects
it okay stop all right back here here
rejects it there we go okay now all
their different color is that what's
going on
beams are still wrongly said okay narrow
reject that ah Purdy now it's like
Google yeah okay so is that what I'm
supposed to do not yet beams wrongly set
air are rejected and that's something
else I think yellow before it was it
orangish just make sure that it doesn't
want it another one like seem in the
right position
oh dear Lord and do what all right what
I'm gonna do is what I usually do and
this might be a mistake here I'm
probably going but I like to keep the
ending in its entirety in one episode
miss seems like it's gonna be the actual
official ending so I'm gonna save and we
are going to get this in the next
episode
all right so thank you all so much for
watching I am really excited to see the
ending of this and how this is all gonna
play out so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye bye